[Music]
in angry x news o submitted by JK news
2020
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you a
restaurant owner claims her petty
ex-boyfriend changed her business's
voicemail to turn away customers
what was it hi DC's rat stew restaurant
you'll get right here by the best rat
the very best come here to get the rat
[ __ ] in everything you eat dude I got
clown on because I was the only person
left in like 20 18 still leaving like a
voicemail that's like like hi I'm not
here right now leave me a message you
have a voicemail
I did like 20 18 I'm like an
embarrassing you hide your favorite song
in the background
no I just says hey nightmare right now
the Mia message did you say her name oh
maybe I was scared I say my name cuz I'm
like what F someone I have I miss
someone gets might holding my number
that I don't want them to write then
they get it confirmed so like it was
left over for when I thought like you
know casting directors or my agent will
call or whatever so I was like hey you
know I thought it you got to be
professional and then I realized no one
else how to greet when I was a kid I
used to romanticize the idea that one
day I would have a voicemail with my
wife and now we're the greens and we're
not home right now
I love all that and then the kids are in
the back who has a landline anymore
nobody our family one I still remember
the one that I was in cuz it was me and
my dad and it was like all I want to do
is do a zoom zoom and boom boom leave a
message you did a combo with you yeah I
used to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then on
mine I used to be like Hello
Oh like I'll just [ __ ] with the other
night my best friend did that once and
then I was just like hey Krystal with
the log and I'm like talking and then
she and then like she continues it and
she was just like oh yeah all my she's
good
I'm like yeah so so are you gonna come
over and then she goes no way really and
I'm like are you even listening to me
and I'm just like yeah what's the worst
is when you have to leave a message that
person many times and then it's like a
guy damn and I gotta sit for three
minutes is usually a star sign oh my god
Peyman real quick star all right fast
forwards it but we don't need that
anymore these days right nope we don't
we don't mean it it's like well I left a
text to voice mail I messaged them on
Instagram a message I'm on Twitter
hey this is Tony's pizza is that what
happens cuz I don't I don't when I call
places they don't even have a answering
yeah press 1 for billing press 2 for
more options where do you call
mom-and-pop places that's probably what
it is yeah they just ring forever and
then I figure that they're busy or they
don't want to talk to me new insurance
oh yeah what what the [ __ ] kind of
private conversations y'all having right
now no we just we just sealed the deal
on new insurance reverse we're very
excited well he goes my insurance
companies want to talk to me because it
takes forever to get a home someone and
I was like we got no insurance
that's wonderful exciting adult things
okay so this story here it sounds boring
it's about this Vietnamese barbecue spot
oh yes named Capital City barbecue and
they started this business back in 2015
in Michigan and it's this like
boyfriend/girlfriend that started that
hilley's barbecue so initially this was
a cellphone store owned by the
girlfriend who's Vietnamese and so she
got like she gave her then-boyfriend
about sixty seven thousand dollars
because he's a contractor yeah it's a
lot of money to renovate her to change
it or to add a restaurant two cell
phones a cell phone and restaurant
[ __ ] here
he like he took care of the barbecuing
stuff wow what a collapse she embraced
like like was because she always had a
dream of opening up her own Vietnamese
restaurant and like doing her family
recipes and stuff I thought she had a
dream to sell barbecue while people buy
cellphone I don't know I feel like she
should have opened a fireplace so we
could be like cellphones yeah you should
get paid for that so then they ended up
opening up this cell phone video meas
barbecue restaurant but then eventually
she ended up shutting down the cell
phone part and extended her seating for
her restaurant and then in July uh her
and her ex-boyfriend Regan Regan phase
it up splitting up which then he went
all crazy like psycho ex-boyfriend he
ended up as Vietnamese no he's a white
guy oh no way
Oh Regan races yeah the Vietnamese girl
friend her name is Lin so Regan and Lin
so then Regan ended up so because he set
up the restaurant like with a lot of
Vital like things that in business needs
he ended up at one point right before
Thanksgiving stealing the smoker that
they would use for for the barbecue the
most important thing yeah so it's uh
nearly fourteen thousand dollar smoker
again he stole it from the restaurant
the day before the midnight the day
before Thanksgiving and she had to like
pull some money together that's grand
theft body no because he was able to
provide a receipt for it because at the
time like you know they were collabing
ons like they were co-owners or whatever
but in reality she said that yeah she
would let him like have the co-owner
title whatever cuz they did build it
together but she said that she wouldn't
legally do it unless he put in the same
amount of money that she invested and
then that's what like they would do that
but then but because of the fact that he
did set up those vital things including
the voicemail he ended up taking that
phone number and changing the voicemail
it said happy holidays from capital city
barbeque due to the holidays we will be
taking an extended leave until March
first we look forward to your business
and seeing you after March first have a
happy holiday thank you
so then that's when she realized like
[ __ ] like they like dropped like crazy
yeah so then she malicious yeah she
ended up having me go on Facebook and
having this message that said dear our
value customers I would like to take a
moment to say thank you and happy
holidays from our culinary team at CC
BBQ we also have a very important an
urgent message regarding the business I
would like everyone to know if you try
to place it an order over the phone with
the last the previous phone number a
message on our voicemail says we are
closed until March it is not true our
phone line has been stolen by an
unethical person who is not a part of
our restaurant he is trying to hurt our
business in any way that he can we
cannot get our old phone number back
however we have a new phone number
and they give the phone numbers yeah so
then that post went viral and then like
that's how we know about this story and
then also this restaurant showed up on
guy Ferry theories diners drive-ins and
dives cell phones and barbeque back in
20 must be good so that's how like her
restaurant like was booming and like on
TripAdvisor and everything like oh great
business and but the thing that she's
really sad about is the fact that that
phone number that he now owns is all
over the restaurant all over like other
web sites like TripAdvisor and stuff can
she sue failure and barbecue info
deserve everything yes and now she's
looking she has she's got names like a
gift shop of who trying to work out like
what can like what can they do give
that's a lot of financial loss exactly
he's hurting the business directly so
this is Lynn and this was the Facebook
post I just read and there are about you
cus that that guy is that the guy's is
the boyfriend oh look at his face then
that's way older than I picture yeah you
thought like a young boy no because yeah
that sounds like a younger person thing
oh wait a second but I've seen them on
the show oh yeah oh [ __ ]
crazy yeah I think he actually speaks
Vietnamese - Oh crazy yeah yeah I think
I saw that episode where do you watch
Food Network I love food shows and I
watch house flippers and pool key I
watch HGTV don't [ __ ] with me but uh we
watch house hunter don't you dare [ __ ]
with me I'll watch [ __ ] all day long
we watch property brothers dude so no we
don't they look alike
once feeding Joe zooey deschanel really
which one exactly all right I am she
tags on to business one or the the guy
worth [ __ ] big twins I was just like
how could she date someone was such a
terrible sense of humor that's all I
thought so lost if you don't watch the
show which I don't that shows that
extraordinary home we love extrude tiny
homes I get claustrophobic
I can't I like I like those doomsday
bunker [ __ ] those are tight oh yeah
Doomsday Preppers that don't show to you
these show the people buying them to
like you like they're like what does it
have the freezer that goes in the back
what about air filtration yeah I love
that [ __ ] yeah that shit's dough it's a
car it's an actual good show it's not
like an other trash American Pickers cuz
it's like Pawn Stars where it's just an
excuse to learn a story Pawn Stars is
the same [ __ ] episode everything oh I
was thinking storage wars
I like storage wars I like it when the
storage guy gets he's like oh this is
gonna be sick 15 G's and then it's like
socks and boxes of [ __ ] but yeah back to
this story here that couple they were
doing for nine years I don't know if I
could ever destroy or maliciously hurt
someone's money you're petty enough
you're very pretty though
no but not like that too much energy for
Joe yeah that's a lot of energy yeah
yeah yeah but also like it depends on
how they did me wrong because I get
satisfaction through violence Sam so
hurting someone publicly shamefully
money whatever I don't care man I does
it yeah and if they have people that
that that that can get hurt through the
crossfire like let's say
like they have kids or whatever I'm like
well [ __ ] it you know like her yeah the
employees like all this and I'm like
well that's their money that's their
business whatever I rather just murder
her like something that's better
[ __ ] bummer so it's more relatable so
the kid what has no mom now dude I have
the camp naman that no money he could
take over the business take over the
business well yeah I mean it's pretty
cool of her though because no matter
what he's thrown at her she like
overcomes it because that that's a bad
Thanksgiving thing she ended up buying a
new smoker not the same one and it was
only she was only the smoke she was only
able to smoke two turkeys at a time and
so she was up all night trying to meet
her Thanksgiving orders so she's a
[ __ ] hustler
dude can you imagine not this guy he
thinks he's completely reckoner and he
drives by the properties like hey you're
still in business and then like the muon
number coming out now like now just
blowing up in hit it's like you're great
cuz try to still Christmas couldn't do
it so much support from people that's
why they say don't get even get ahead
because she's really winning by doing
this and it's like just staying in her
Lane you're going for and what is he
doing and how much is he making oh he's
got a sick smoker he's spending a lot of
energy trying to destroy her and that's
what I'm saying instead of making money
and yeah continue but if you keep
changing the voicemail all you want you
could is if it's defunct they wouldn't
work anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]